how are you Reese I'm doing great rich
and I I was not aware of that little
little historical I think something come
on you know I'll be honest with you
Reese I'm not feeling the the the hype
here for the National Championship game
I'm wondering what what you're feeling I
just don't I don't know if it's because
we've seen the matchup three straight
years already to with it all on the line
before and tonight's you know the fourth
am I mistaken
I hope so rich because I think in terms
of setup the only game that I can think
of certainly in this generation that's
even comparable is Texas USC now one of
the reasons that we remember Texas USC
so fondly is because it was a great game
and we don't know how this one will play
out I'm sure there is a little bit of
familiarity that you know that impacts
the way people feel about it but I mean
these two teams this is this is
excellent this is like alex reisher
later Celtics this is this is the
pinnacle of the sport
so I hope that there's a there's a lot
of buzz about it and some quarters I do
think that maybe you know the lack of
ticket demand because it's difficulty
for the two fan bases at least for their
prominent primarily located difficulty
getting here might impact a little bit
inside the stadium tonight but you know
overall this is a tremendous
championship matchup and my judge know
it is I'll be watching I'm saying I'm
not gonna be watching I was just you
know just wondering you know if because
as you pointed out it's geographically
unsound for the two campuses it's in
pac-12 country and but neither here nor
there let's let's discuss this this
matchup for which I am personally
excited what do you think give me give
me a key give me a key for tonight to
look for I think just to me the biggest
thing it's really it's almost boring
because it sounds real football head
stuff about the lines of scrimmage but I
think Alabama with the injury to
Christian Miller who's really their best
edge rusher leaves them without a
quicker twist kind of guy who can get to
the quarterback and I think that could
be a problem against Trevor Lawrence
because they've got big Racine
Alabama has some youth in the secondary
at least a corner that could be a big
issue and then on the other side the
interior of Clemson's often declined
while it has been productive over the
course of season it has it it hasn't
dealt with anybody like Quinn and
Williams and if he can disrupt them in
the middle then I think that's where
that's where the game lies obviously and
then protecting to uh if you know if
Alabama protects to it and they'll be
very effective offense last thing I'm
excited to watch to her I really am I
mean we only got a half of well a half
plus in overtime last year but just
watching him I'm I'm I'm and he's full
go right there's there's no question
about his ready no no question I mean
he's still been a little bit sore rich
but he's ready to go he's practiced you
know he obviously threw the ball great
against Oklahoma this is a much
different defense for sure I I don't you
know I don't know that he's quite as
quick and as fast is you know maybe he
was before he was hurt but some of their
some of their coaches told me this week
that they felt as if he's probably
healthier now than he has been at any
point since he was since he first banged
up his knee against Arkansas midseason
so they they're there no concerns at
this moment anyway with to it is help
okay you have a who's picking the game
tonight you're gonna have it's just one
game so are you having a celebrity
picker picker we have a celebrity cast
of thousands in fact I'm sitting in
trailers I tip Kelly right now he'll be
on the show with us Gus Malzahn surround
Jim Mora you know who works with us now
is involved control or show and so we've
got all kinds of guys but we don't have
necessarily the celebrity guest picker
will leave the celebrities do imagine
dragons of Lil Wayne with a halftime
show my kid my sons are really excited
about imagine dragons tonight that's big
so you're legitimately directly next to
Chip Kelly right now is what you're
saying I am and what I'm watching Kipp
tie his tie how's it now how's it dead
well as he Windsor as you double Windsor
gone what is he he said you struggling
with a little bit are you what he
doesn't know what is he in all
seriousness Reese what does he think
watching Nick Foles doing what he's
happen I haven't asked if you want me to
end the phone do it real quick real
quick reason you know my Rich Eisen or
give up audacity wants to know if you
think about what Nick Foles is doing
right now
he says Nick's the best there you go
that's a quote that's a rich rich Eisen
show exclusive here okay so you know
Reese Reese Davis here on the Rich Eisen
show so tonight do we expect do you
think a close game do you think this is
really gonna come down to it because the
last time these two teams as we all know
you know faced when they weren't when it
wasn't for all the marbles it didn't
really go very well what do you expect
from tonight Reese well I I think close
and I think there will be a lot of
points rich this is a different Clemson
team I mean I really have a lot of
respect for Kelly Bryant as a player in
the young manatees nowhere near the
pasture that Trevor Lawrence is and has
changed cousins offense so I think
you're gonna have something that much
closer to the two championship meetings
which 45 40 and 35 31 that's the type of
game you're going to see tonight I
believe between these two I think you're
gonna see a lot of big plays a lot of
offense and whoever can get key
defensive stops will will walk out with
that trophy Bruce Davis here on the Rich
Eisen show last one for you because
you're gonna turn the page to college
basketball whereas you know based on the
way that things went for the university
Michigan football team I've been focused
on college basketball a lot earlier than
I have in recent years Reese hmm and I
am thinking this is what I was thinking
that Michigan hops in the DeLorean and
on behalf of the Fab five that got
rejected by Duke returns the favor and
does it to their version of the Fab five
this year what do you think about that
idea rece Davis that would be that would
be perfect symmetry and I wouldn't be
surprised
I watched Michigan the other night
playing I've seen him a couple of times
but even though they're not shooting as
well as John would like at the moment
you know they will that's a really
really good team I think you've got a
lot of happy times in store one
tournament rolls around for the
Wolverines issue I really do yeah you do
so do you think it's possible though
they can do that design and all those
guys and coach can I do yeah absolutely
think it's possible these you're not
just saying that to be a nice guy that
you are I'm I'm really I'm really not I
mean who has the most talented team
there's no doubt about that but how many
times does the most talented team win
that tournament
not all the time yeah so Michigan is
plenty good enough to win the national
championship and they're really good on
defense which you know sometimes a young
team has no matter how talented they can
struggle with that aspect on a big stage
I really like Michigan's opportunity to
make the final board if you make it
there again certainly you have a chance
to win national champions yes I did
Reese have a great time tonight enjoy
well uh you know I'll be watching the
entire time and then I look forward to
having you back on and thanks for the
Chip Kelly exclusive that you got for me
you have that's rhys-davies at ESPN
underscore rece Davis the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience